ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina puntata oggi faremo
una cosa meravigliosa che non è fare
male ma fai un piatto che in realtà è
utile non tanto per sfamarci quanto per
a pagarci sto parlando dei pop corn con
la salsa al caramello muro su un
grandissimo fan di pop corn ne fanno
mezzo le gare quello che vi faremo
vedere è il procedimento per creare
questa salsa che è perfetta per essere
messe in salvo cori quando ancora un
pochino calda e più malleabile ma allo
stesso tempo secondo me è perfetto anche
la mettere all interno di un barattolo
lasciato dino raffreddare fate prendere
una cosa assistenza un pochino più
spalmabile e buttarla su un crostino
direttamente nell'esofago insomma col
pugno per fare la salsa muoveremo
bisogno di zucchero panna fresca
trent'anni tabù crim lab on the bash
burro sale e noi lo prendiamo sempre
ormai rosa dell'himalaya
non chiedetemi quale sia la differenza
se non l'avrà di commercio date
sull'himalaya loro e infine abbiamo
bisogno di pop corn che noi faremo
facilmente al microonde e che poi il
fattore ma all'interno diciamo di questa
padella sono che adesso un po paura ora
che questa ventura diventando una cosa
seria
spero 80 si genera per prima cosa vorrei
ringraziare unicorn i cookie unicorn
l'unico hans i cookies che è un canale
dal quale abbiamo preso questa ricetta
vi mettiamo anche qui sotto il link se
volete veder noi fa piacere condividere
diciamo mettevi dal suo caso si iscrive
la campanella mattera delle sue
campanelli cioè attivate anche le sue
campanelle il suo canale tutto quello
che volete è bello condividere insomma
specialmente anche come segno di
gratitudine quando qualcuno ti insegna
qualcosa una cosa che dovremmo imparare
a fare sempre più spesso non hai detto
quanti grammi di zucchero servono 225
cosa importantissima mettere tutto
quanto lo zucchero in maniera omogenea
sulla padella quindi canto proprio un
letto di zuppe o fiamma media come siamo
già il burro 84 grammi
843 grandi possono andare bene lì per
farsi fare questo punto mancano in
questo modo se rendiamo omogenei il
calore non avremo parti dello zucchero
più calde rispetto ad altre che quindi
andranno a sciogliersi troppo
velocemente rischiando addirittura di
bruciarsi quindi rendere un sapore
troppo amarostico e ma rossi non esiste
come termine re amarlo mi sembrava
convintissimo enrico quando ha detto
amarostico così convinto che ho detto a
conosce un termine che non conosco io
adesso sto iniziando a stancare lo
zucchero dal fondo in modo evitare che
si bruci e lo sto ogni volta ricco e
sinceri riordinando riorganizzando
agnostico 15 a spezzare tutti quanti
cristalli più grossi ok di però come ti
sta avvenendo più vincoli stanza
all'altra volta perché noi l'altra volta
abbiamo messo pure l'acqua questi non da
dire solo di wow preferisce essere
chiamato molto concessi non ho idea
perchè l'ho mai visto per il burro
leggero sofri pino e amalgamarlo il più
possibile appena il burro sarà tutto
quanto sciolto spegniamo il fuoco e
aggiungiamo la panna che è motivo per
cui consigliano delle pentole con dei
bordi abbastanza alti in modo da evitare
che schizzi comunque tutto quanto
potrebbe succedere il delirio a
tranquilli l'amore c'è 25 g e normale
che faccio questa cosa è normale ma che
faccia cosa in questa cosa sembra acqua
sporca e brando stagno pop corn in salsa
di stagno adesso di nuovo sul fuoco per
far unire bene la panna a il caramello
hai dimenticato la panna che filma
google stato io
e arrivato il nostro producer per il
pezzo che dice mentre concorde vanno nel
microonde
io aggiungo un pochino di sale al
caramello mi sembra bello compio andiamo
mettiamo i pop corn al burro e pop corn
sembra che schizzino da tutte le parti
sempre quasi meglio che se al cielo
sopra è pieno di caramello non riesco a
capire se è un piatto buono o disgustoso
erano dubbi che tuttora se qualcosa di
disgustoso che tu come lo trova occhio
disgustoso cruciale però è buona
vorrei dire a tutte le persone che mi
seguono anche voi non potete capire
quanto sia difficile genere con questi
due ma si mangia con le mani sta roba
non ho contate forchetta cucchiaio
quelle male ma avete schifo ecco e mamma
se ci siamo facciamo i figli da anche
l'ok alla sua parte della trota non
mangia pure in un sacchetto magri atti
magari prima che carina con quella che
ci sono delle persone troppo adorabile
del mondo il mondo dovrebbe essere fatto
lo dico sempre di più persone come
quelle che seguono questo canale è meno
come quelle che lo fanno
ora andremo a mangiare a fine pranzo
essere molto dolce mamma mia il suo
commento è stato mamma mia
dopo il pranzo seguente passa all'aspro
limoni le gengive finché non gli si
ritirano abbiamo appena finito di
mangiare quindi che sia il momento per
il dolce siamo tutti quanti felici
tranne gianmarco spade che gli sto
chiedendo di assaporare invaso da è
privo di fare l'assaggio come sempre vi
invito a iscrivervi a questo canale
metterci un pollice su per il e farci
sapere soprattutto quali sono alte
ricette che vorreste vedere ha detto ciò
sino a fatelo detto ciò fatelo davvero
il tuo dire che possiamo assaggiare
facciamo un esperimento quale no
l'atleta ma non lo faccio
voglio solo capire una cosa si ribalta
si ribalta capito quanto è incollato
fino al braciere
non sempre però era curioso balze
andiamo
non mi piace non era terribile ma
stucchevole cioè io conosco bene il
sapore della caramella
secondo me è molto buono però ti piace
la caramella multi stucchevole dire
tanto mangia tutto ma è lo sappiano e
quindi caramella mou è garantita e lei
dopodiché riusciresti a bagnanti
qualcosa no tutto no però che nei rami
tempo cioè è secondo te la senti a
caramella mou salsa le il dolce li
preferisco quelli più classici numerica
si mangia burro non è male ma non mi
rimangerei mai guarda un film
ne prendo con normali che toccò a
qualcosa non va ingestibili si piace
boccone di pane meno annunciava ci
vediamo martedì prossimo in quella nuova
puntata di ciao